that's dope man and shout out to buster
too
i seen a interview with buster was
talking about the surgery
uh surgery he had and actually [ __ ] me
up because that's the same surgery i had
and i never really heard nobody like
talk about that [ __ ] [ __ ] like
it scared me from the perspective of
you know when some [ __ ] happened to you
you don't feel it
no that's a bad analogy you have a
you have a uh you smoke weed yeah you
ever smoke a bunch of weed and then walk
in the mall
and wonder why everybody looking at you
you think maybe it's sneaky you know you
got the new sneak you got some new
yeezys on and you don't have a similar
uh
and you don't realize you smell like the
back of the dispensary like it all just
came in and you opened it and rubbed it
all over your skin but you're high
so you don't you're cool you don't smell
that [ __ ] that's meat oh i don't
i smell amazing i still smell like the
cologne i sprayed this morning
you smoked eight blunts since then meals
you don't smell like that but i'm in it
so i don't
see it i remember the first time i seen
wayne have a seizure
on the jet in the air now i have
seizures
i have seizures in my sleep oh wow like
scariest [ __ ] ever so but
every time i've had a siege in my sleep
i wake up and i'm cool
like yo i'm good you were there when
wayne had a seizure
like two different times scariest [ __ ]
i've ever seen in my life
i it because it made me feel you know
it made me feel like oh that's what i
look like
and then when he got up he was cool he
was like yo
was his like lean usage that bad
i don't know if it was i don't know if
it was the lean because i don't sip lean
right i don't and i have seizures i
think that that's what everyone says
everyone's kind of
uh come to that conclusion i don't i
don't know if this i don't i can't
really say it because once again
i own sibling and i have a history of it
you never sipped lean
around all the meat i tried it one time
but i tried it
was quadruple cupping i tried it by
mistake i mean gutter was in hit factory
one time and
uh i had a sun kiss and you know you got
the white cups with the ice right i
poured it in there but i didn't realize
that
uh he had some lean and some sun kissed
too you know what i'm saying somewhere
so
when i hit the cup i'm like oh this [ __ ]
tastes sweet
you know tastes good actually you know
what i'm saying
but i'm like i'm thinking maybe you know
it's just a good ass sun kiss right now
i caught one
hit it again i remember like oh i was
just like
slumped beat playing like i'm trying to
get up
i feel good though but i'm just wow
comfortable like and he's like no [ __ ]
you drunk my cup [ __ ]
i'm like nah that was my cup like my
meals your cup over there [ __ ] this my
cup right here i'm like
oh [ __ ] and that's when i realized the
whole time i was drinking got a gutter
cup
did everyone like was it like a panic
when
when like he had a seizure because
that's an alarming thing to witness
especially wayne yeah
yeah that [ __ ] is a panic but it was a
panic for me because everybody looking
at me like
mills you do it's like yo i've never
i'm i'm i usually be in the mode he's in
right now
and i remember when he woke up he's like
yo i'm good everybody you know
and they had the ems on the thing let me
get the [ __ ] off my jet
because we had to land the jet we was
going to la we had to land the jet
for the ems to get on and now we got to
put the jet back up in the air so
rich [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm not i don't live on
rich [ __ ] [ __ ] even
with money i want to live on broke [ __ ]
[ __ ] you live like you broke you'll stay
rich
right man put this [ __ ] back up in the
[ __ ] air y'all know how much
this [ __ ] gas
costs i was like that guy has a point
right now
we did land his jet now we have to put
it back up in the air and land it again
it's a whole nother fee that none of us
have paid i mean he had a seizure though
now granted i'm like i get it i get
where he's coming from
oh y'all get the [ __ ] off my jack come
on i got to get to la because he got to
get that later
do an event like a video game event or
something like that now you know you
don't do that
now you had to pay for the gas to put
the jet back up again
and you got to give them back that
deposit they gave you because you ain't
show up to that event you lost twice
today
um jack go back up in the air he like
milsie
he like that [ __ ] was that bad it was
serious like that
and i promise you i i did not want to
you know you don't want to really say
that but i'm like
[ __ ] was bad bro that was the first time
i probably told him something he didn't
want to hear it's like bro that [ __ ] was
the scariest [ __ ] i've ever seen in my
life
like like i don't want to see you like
that ever again my [ __ ]
he's like word he's like believe that
blood love you know what i'm saying
yeah and then after that when we land he
went to
he went to the hospital and that's when
he stayed overnight and you know
but that [ __ ] was scary man cause it's
like and that's why i said i don't want
to i don't want to put it to the lean
i don't you know what i'm saying because
when i have seizures
it's from overworking myself it's high
blood pressure and low sugar count it's
it's an imbalance you know what i'm
saying so it ain't
it ain't perks and zannies and lean
cause i got a history of this [ __ ]
and i don't do none of that [ __ ] right
you know what i'm saying like the
closest to a pill i'm gonna get his
partying with an e pill or molly back in
the day it's just it does seem like that
that is so
different people bodies you know they it
should hit different but
that that's some scary [ __ ] damn was
that like something where like you think
that like it maybe changed the way he
thought about
some of the recreational use of stuff he
had going on probably
probably when you almost die your life
flash before you you think about all
sorts of [ __ ]
that's real that's where you get shot
you get stabbed you get jumped
natural causes i remember when the
doctor told me i got
you know i got six months if i don't get
this surgery
and then he said i'm gonna let you be
with your lady in six months and walked
out
like damn i'm gonna let you figure out
if you want to get this surgery or do
you want to wait it out a little bit
right and at that time it's april you my
daughter
three years old you telling me i'm not
making it
to and then when you go through all that
it's like no i gotta
put everything back in perspective and i
promised myself since 2015
i wouldn't deprive my fans i wouldn't
cheat myself i wouldn't waste my time
overthinking [ __ ] or holding the music
hostage